Ryan Jessica I know you guys have been
collaborators since you were children
literally right
um how did this project find its way to
you and what interested you in making
this movie I know you're the big space
nerd
that's exactly right Ryan and I have
been best friends since we were little
kids in Atlanta
um and Ryan's always been a big space
Enthusiast and wanted to be an astronaut
but ended up in filmmaking and we always
knew we wanted to make a space film and
we had a few opportunities but nothing
really landed with us until this project
we had a dinner and film 45 peteburg's
company in amblin Steven Spielberg's
company had had this idea and pitched it
to us and Ryan and I at this dinner just
looked at each other and said like that
this is the one we knew it was the one I
mean it's an amazing log line you know
it's a it's an adventure story of a
robot supposed to live 90 days and live
15 years and the log line got us hooked
but we still didn't really know what we
were in for at that point and we
discovered so much more about the story
and the weight of it along the way by
the way space Enthusiast is so much
nicer than space nerds well I did say
nerd normally and we are nerds
immediately I was just joking about that
a few minutes ago actually it's a very
everyone we always talk about nerding
out I mean that's what this project was
you know working with Island which I'm
sure we'll talk about and working with
these amazing people who does such great
work like it was it was a pretty heavy
nerdy project which was great and I I'm
as a proud nerd I will say I mean that
with affection so Ryan when you heard
this pitch where you instantly like you
knew you were doing it you probably
didn't have to convince her too much
yeah I think we knew right away we gave
each other this look like this is this
is the one but it was the beginning of a
really unpredictable journey and I think
uh we thought the log Line's great and
we were working with amblin and they
brought an industrial Light Magic to us
and we thought okay we have this amazing
way of taking the audience to Mars in a
way that's never been done before
through these visual effects and then uh
Jess got access to the archive that NASA
had shot which was almost a thousand
hours of footage so usually we're verite
filmmakers meaning we're following
something unfolding but we thought even
though this story opportunity had
already had her beginning middle and end
through that Earthbound story and the
archival and then the visual effects on
Mars which were going to be photoreal
and based on all the real photographs
and data that we might be able to take
the audience on that Journey day by day
year by year instead of it being
retrospective what we didn't know was
who were the who were the human beings
that were going to be in the movie and I
I think if we're being honest we thought
that that was going to be the biggest
challenge we had this preconceived
notion that scientists and Engineers
maybe wouldn't be the most emotional
storytellers and we ended up being
completely wrong and Jess actually began
pre-interviewing all these people
including Jennifer and Doug and
everybody you know we only have 11 human
beings in our film because you can only
fit so many but there were dozens of
incredible people that we talked to who
all had their own singular individual
bond with this Rover their own anecdotes
of how it went side by side in their
life and so really I think the film
became all about the humanity Behind
These Rovers because the rovers are just
an extension of these of these human
beings I mean the the people the humans
in this are so fascinating and Jennifer
and Doug I'm curious when you first
heard about this project is this is this
the sort of thing that you would
normally do or was it specifically
because this story was so special that
you wanted to be a part of it
we missions like these are very lucky in
that they tend to get a lot of attention
from the documentary business from the
TV business from media in general
because they are they're cool they're
exciting they're enticing they make good
you know above the fold from page
postcards and stuff like that but the
sort of stories that normally get told
are the more traditional this is how the
Rover was built this is what it went and
did and this is what it found role
credits it's it's the Rover story I've
seen Through The Eyes of the people I
think when I first realized this was
something a little different was when I
realized it wasn't so much the story of
the mission Through The Eyes of the
people it was the story of the people
Through The Eyes of the Rover it was
flipping the formula and that's when I
realized that it was going to probably
fill this this hole that that some of us
kind of on the deck are the Good Ship
opportunities you went down we had this
kind of emotional hole because it it
ended really quickly and whilst it was
six months of trying to recover it but
but you're left with this this kind of
emotion hold you you worked as a team on
this thing and in some respects I think
what this has done is patch that hole
and serve as a tool that we can then
pass on to other people to say
this is why we care about projects like
this this is what being on a project
like this is all about because people
were probably on to the next project
already and you probably didn't really
get a chance to more knobby
yeah in fact I had been on to the next
project and the next project and was
doing perseverance at the time but
opportunity was a legacy on which these
other Rovers were built and as far as my
interest in the film as Doug said there
were lots of documentaries over the
years that were done on the different
missions and Mars rovers and initially I
didn't really have an idea that this was
any different than those and then they
asked for some family pictures and and
more stories about us than stories about
the science and and I thought oh that's
that's interesting and I think the thing
that really strikes me being a team
member of all these Rovers including
opportunity in spirit is just the
uniqueness of all the people even though
there are only 11 people in the film it
takes everyone with a unique skill
hundreds thousands of people to make
those Rovers work and I felt like we
sort of came up with the same thing with
this documentary where there's a a
pairing of people with unique skills and
talents and as an engineer we're not
we're not always the best folks to tell
our stories and so that is what I really
appreciated was finding people who who
could get that story out of us in a way
that maybe we couldn't tell it and then
tell it to the world such that anybody
can watch this movie and be interested
Blake can you sort of talk about going
into this you know did you have ideas of
things that you wanted to lean into or
maybe you want to avoid I I think I read
an interview where you said you were you
were actually initially hesitant to use
the piano because it's sort of a Trope
well not a Trope it's more of a No-No
composers like if you're in space you're
not using a piano you got to be big and
I'm like I don't know about that
um but I happen to I've been working
with these two beautiful humans for 10
years now and I happen to be at that
dinner
on the 12th where the whole project was
pitched and I being uh we're going with
nerd or Enthusiast yeah space nerd um
Star Wars was the first thing that told
eight-year-old me that even film
composing was a thing so I've been so
we're sitting at this dinner
and they go what do you think what do
you mean what do you think you just said
space and Mars we're doing this right
and Jessica said well what are you
thinking what do you hear and I said
well we're gonna need an orchestra which
was cool because
in a lot of our movies there's no money
but this from the very beginning stages
we all got to kind of throw in what we
needed
um so we began planning that but then
the this idea came to me that
I mean they're they're like children The
Rovers you know hearing their stories
through the whole thing they're they're
like these
these two Fragile Kids up there in cold
lonely space and I just thought you know
what's more lonely than just like one
piano note and that's how the score
opens so that was the idea and forgive
me because music is not my area of
expertise but it feels like each of the
Rovers kind of has their own theme um
and maybe even their own instruments
yeah they they have I mean very
different personalities right so they
they got their own themes um Doug didn't
get his own personal theme but yet
but what but what I did do with this
movie is uh I I felt like I had two
roles one was to to make you as Mark
will say um make you care about these
boxes of bolts and wires so it was this
fine line of how much do you push the
emotion because at some point you're
like that's just a bunch of box a box of
wires and then if you push it too far
you're like come on it's just a box of
wires so we were constantly riding this
line of of balancing the emotion and
then the other thing for me is is these
real humans these people who care so
um Doug has this great line in the movie
where he says you you only get this kind
of experience this kind of Adventure
once and I thought wow you know this guy
before I'd ever met him and Jennifer
they're gonna see this movie you know
with narratives those characters don't
exist so they're not never going to see
the movie but they're going to see this
movie so I there's a sense of uh
I don't know burden I guess
to make them experience the film how
they experience the adventure
yeah that's a lot of pressure now that I
think about it I mean it's still just
music so we like it no worries Mark I
love that you you literally just won an
Oscar for creating sound on a fictional
planet in Dune
um how do you design the sound for Mars
how do you know what Mars sounds like
where do you even begin
well when I started the project I only
had a sort of a cursory understanding of
the meteorology of Mars we you know we
we knew we wanted Mars to sound
like something that made sense for what
we understand about its climate so the
first the first sound I just attempted
to design was the atmosphere of Mars and
in the middle of that Adventure
um uh we found out from NASA that
perseverance the Rover that's currently
on Mars had actually captured sounds on
Mars it's the first time microphones
have been placed on a a robot or a Rover
like this and I got to hear what an
alien planet sounds like so among other
things I I took those actual sounds of
the sound of Mars and turned that into
an immersive soundscape that we use
every time we're on the surface of the
planet
um sort of apropos of of of what Blake
was saying I felt that same burden
because I I I didn't want Doug and
Jennifer or anyone else to see this
movie and hear sounds of Opie because
they knew what those sounds were like
and and have that not be the Sonic
equivalent of photorealistic I wanted it
to be audio accurate so I also had the
good opportunity to go to JPL and record
the sounds of the remaining uh Opie
chassis it didn't have a nav cam on it
in the Mars yard so I captured the
sounds of motors and wheels and servos
and as it traversed a Terrain that's
been built to mimic the surface of Mars
so yeah in in so many ways I I felt the
pressure of the documentary to be
accurate and be honest and truthful with
sound unlike a movie like Dune where we
have the latitude
to do really kind of anything you know
when you see things you've never seen
before you should arguably hear things
you've never heard before this felt
different and that's an additional
burden that I don't usually have in
narrative filmmaking well I want to
remind everyone this movie is actually
streaming on Amazon Prime so you can
watch it again I want to thank you all
so much for being here and again
congratulations on a beautiful movie
thank you thank you thank you all for
coming here on a Sunday morning
[Applause]